dans ce même avec shoah je le disais
c'est le texte même de votre film et je
disais moi j'ai pas vu le film et je me
dis que en lisant ce test que toutes les
images sont dans les mots j'ai cette
impression
alors je suis persuadé que peut-être du
joaillier le film et je me dis que j'ai
l'impression de voir le film de toutes
ces images que l son contenu vraiment
renfermé dans tous les maux oui mais ça
me demeurent obscures à moi même ça me
demeure mystérieux à moi même toute
l'histoire de ce film est de ce livre
est une histoire gigogne c'est un peu
comme les poupées russes
parce que finalement j'ai fait ce film
sur le passé et ce film qui évoque le
passé avec les seules images du présent
et il évoque avec ces images du présent
au point qui m'arrive de rencontrer des
gens ou de recevoir des lettres de gens
qui sont convaincus tellement leur
imagination à travailler d'avoir vu dans
le film des documents alors qu'il n'y a
pas un seul document
tout est tourné aujourd'hui et oui mais
sur les lieux sur les lieux est belle
c'est un film qui est tout entier bâti
avec des lieux et des paroles à savoir
que la la parole donne vie au lieu
d'aujourd'hui est le lieu donna la
parole une sorte de force étrange simone
de beauvoir le dit dans sa préface le
grand art de claude lanzmann le faire
parler les lieux des ressuscités à
travers les voix et par delà les mots
d'exprimer l'indicible par des visages
et les lieux sont et effectivement on
voit les lieux aussi à travers les nous
c'est ce que j'ai découvert en en
faisant les sous titres avec deux
collaboratrices à moi au des taux de
boca dié irrite les queues en faisant
les sous titres finalement qu'est ce que
c'est que le sous titre le sous titre c
ça ne compte pas dans un film on sait
tués immédiatement par la parole par la
mimique par les mots qui se succèdent et
qui adviennent et à la limite c'est fait
pour être simplement en entrevue dans
une figuration et en faisant les sous
titres je m'amusais allez allez lire à
voix haute et pour précisément parce que
je me disais que la parole selon m
prenez une force extraordinaire et se
passait d'image d'une certaine façon se
passe les images de visages de deux
larmes de silence alors de quoi parle
t-on évidemment des camps des camps de
concentration et d'extermination
d'extermination on apprend des choses on
apprend beaucoup de choses mais par
exemple les juifs d'auschwitz il y avait
des juifs qui habitait au show is now
fait c'est à une ville lui il joue en
course alors ils ont été quand on a
construit quand ils ont été écartés de
la ville et puis et puis sont revenus et
ont les extermine dans le camp là où sa
série sont revenus au camp port et
mourir mais là le premier mouvement
était un mouvement d'expulsion il ya
toujours eu ça dans le dans le nazisme
alors vous donnez vous avez interrogé
les paysans à treblinka
les gens les paysans qui cultivaient
leurs champs à côté du camp aux lisières
même du corps est alors qu'est ce qu'ils
disent ces gens-là ça c'est
extraordinaire les paysans polonais pour
moi ça a été le plus grand choc enfin
d'abord d'arriver là et puis de
découvrir que treblinka qui pour moi
était un nom chargé d'horreur et 1
deux légendes tellement il était associé
à l'horreur de découvrir que ça existe
est bon de voir la pancarte à treblinka
la petite gare de treblinka
enfin l'acte même de la nomination si
vous voulez était capital et je me suis
mis mais personne ne l'avait fait avant
moi et c'est ce que je n'arrive de ne
pas comprendre je me suis mis à
interroger ses paysans c'était en plein
hiver la première fois que j'ai été là
il y avait beaucoup de neige et rôder
dans les villages et je me suis mis à
parler et soudage et je me suis aperçu
que je me suis mis à interroger je me
suis aperçu que je réveiller mettons de
choses il n'y avait pas du tout besoin
de les pousser de les presser pour qu'il
parle c'est une sorte de discours à la
fois légendaire et routinier qu'il se
mettait à tenir et ça a été vraiment
quelque chose d'absolument incroyable
paysans cultivaient leurs champs à côté
du camp ils savaient où ils ne savaient
pas ils savaient ces vaisseaux ils
savaient tous avaient tous et voyez tout
il entendait tout ils santé tout parce
que la pologne entière a pu et jusqu'au
ciel l'odeur des charniers en
décomposition et l'odeur des bûchers
qu'on édifiait précisément pour faire
disparaître les traces de
l'extermination on ouvrait les fossés
ont brûlé pendant des mois
l'école il ya ceux ci là ce sont des
jeunes qui sont dans un dans un train
alors le vieux dans notre compartiment a
vu quelqu'un y regarder ils savent pas
où ils sont il y avait des vaches qui
paissaient et il a demandé mais par
signes ou sommes-nous et l'autre a fait
un drôle de ges à à la gorge
oui alors le voyez et leur site ce n'est
pas dit oui bien sûr alors c'est un
polonais alors du monde et le polonais
fait sa part un geste en disant vous
allez mourir et il est content lors des
roues et simplement d'un geste
d'information hollandais attention vous
allez vous
une coûteuse a été c'est une grande
question et puis je les ai poussés la
russie parce que j'ai pas j'ai pas tout
monté dans le film c'est un film de 9h30
gt350 ils prétendent que c'est un geste
d'avertissement mais c'est pas vrai
c'est un geste ça ne peut pas être un
geste d'avertissement
c'est un geste ça dit oui et pourtant
vous avez un polonais qui vous dit après
les gens quelle occasion s'approcher des
jusqu'en faisait ce geste pour les
avertir oui il dit pour les avertir
qu'ils n'aient pas montré dans le dans
le livre car on ne peut pas tout
imaginer c'est qu'il a un énorme rire
gras à ce moment là et qui donne la clé
enfin du mot avertir alors qu'est ce que
c'est que ces ukrainiens qui sont encore
plus a dit que les ss et céline dont ils
sont encore plus a dit que les
ukrainiens ukrainienne et les temps
c'est autre chose ce sont pas du tout
les paysans polonais qui habitait autour
des camps ce sont les mercenaires
des nazis bon ce sont eux qui
constituent essentiellement la garde des
camps d'extermination
parce que l'ukraine est un pays
traditionnellement terriblement
antisémites et les pays et les pays
baltes a également alors lettons et
estoniens et ukrainiens étaient les
mercenaires nazis dans les camps
d'extermination
il ya le témoignage à l'homme s'appelle
bomba qui est coiffeur est qui et qui
rase les femmes avant d'en faire grâce
pas dans leur coupe les cheveux avant
qu'ils aillent dans les chambres à gaz
dans la chambre à gaz en régate dans la
chambre mais ce bon ba com comment ça se
fait qu'il ait survivants étaient comme
ça c'est par extraordinaire est un héros
parce que c'est un héros c'est comme ça
je ne vais pas raconter j'ai pas du tout
raconté dans le nil dans le film dit
dans le livre les histoires
individuelles de chacun de ces
survivants mais ils sont tous ils sont
une poignée dans le monde aujourd'hui
sont des miraculés
et ce bon bah s'est évadé après avoir
passé trois mois à treblinka
il s'est évadé en passant par la fausse
enflammée du lazare est ce que les
allemands étaient là zarate qu'était
l'hôpital dans lequel on conduisait les
gens âgés les gens malades les infirmes
directement au sortir des trains cela on
ne les envoyait pas aux chambres à gaz
parce que il aurait freiné le bon
déroulement du processus vers les
chambres à gaz
on les conduisait
dans une sorte de petite cabane qui
étaient de proches de la rampe où il y
avait une fois ci on les tué d'une balle
dans la nuque bon et à cause du feu qui
brûlait en permanence ça n'était pas
gardé et bomba s'est évadé en se
couvrant de vêtements et en plongeant
dans la fosse de l'hôpital et ce qui est
très drôle c'est que vous disiez tout à
l'heure à propos de jim du roman de bala
que le camp était son refuge d'une
certaine façon c'est que bon ba n'a pas
pu faire autre chose il est arrivé à
treblinka au mois de septembre 1942
c'est à dire au coeur même de
l'extermination quand elle battait son
plein il s'est évadé trois mois plus
tard en janvier 1943
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il venait de
chester revint à la ville de la vierge
noire de pologne
il n'a pu rien faire d'autre que de
retourner au ghetto de czestochowa oui
assez encore cinq mille juifs au ghetto
le ghetto étant presque un refuge et
ensuite il a été repris quand les
allemands décidé de liquider le ghetto
six mois plus tard il a été repris et ré
embarqué pour treblinka
là il s'est évadé litres il y allait
aussi tous les récits sur les c'est
juste qu'on fait monter dans des camions
et ils sont asphyxiés dans les camions
des camions il y avait des camions gaye
vient est vraiment beaucoup de témoins
il ya des choses incroyables comme ce
camion alors où il ya tous ces élections
dedans et le camion dérape et il
renverse et ils sont à moitié mort ça
c'est très très passionnant pour le pour
le récit polonais pour ce que j'appelais
tout à l'heure la routine et la légende
reno est un tout petit village enfin il
ya quelques maisons alignées le long de
la route
et puis il ya évidemment d'autres
villages autour et tout le monde savait
puisque les camions magasins faisait la
navette sur la route entre l'église et
la forêt la forêt est distante de 7
kilomètres de léglise et ont tué les
gens on les as fixé pendant le trajet il
fallait que les camions et une certaine
vitesse qu'ils n'aillent pas trop vite
parce que les gens n'auraient pas
été tuées ne seraient pas morts au
moment où le camion arrive dans la forêt
donc la vitesse était établie était
calculé bon et voyait ce camion passait
tous les jours et ça c'était la routine
et moi je posais toujours la question de
la première fois parce que c'est
tellement inouïe comment est-ce qu'ils
ont pris cela comment est ce qu'ils ont
accepté reconnu identifier la première
fois que ça s'est passé il évadés
toujours la question de la première fois
il était immédiatement dans la routine
et ce qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'il
y a eu cet accident
là encore un accident et c'est un
accident qui brise la routine bon et
soudain la légende naît le mythe n'est
pas ce que je n'ai pas rencontré un seul
polonais de ce village de reno qui n'ai
prétendu devant moi avoir été lui
personnellement le témoin de cet
accident
or c'est pas vrai c'est un mensonge et
il y a eu un seul témoin je les
retrouver pour mais tous les autres se
sont appropriés cet événement inouï et
l'événement inouïe suscite immédiatement
sa propre légende et son propre mythe
je regardais l'autre jour deux là ont
tous vu dossiers de l'écran et des
terroristes à la retraite le film de
moscow et à la fin il y avait donc un
juif de quartier du sentier qui avait
terroriste entre guillemets donc avait
été un résistant et on lui disait mais
aujourd'hui si vous étiez en présence
d'un nazi et calmement avec une sérénité
assez étonnante il disait si je vends
moins nazi je le tuerais aujourd'hui
alors vous vous avez été vous avez
interrogé des ss alors que dans quel
état psychologique était devant toutes
ces horreurs que vous racontez mais
comment étiez-vous comment avez vous pu
les interroger calmement css mon
problème ne s'était pas de les tuer
j'étais ou bien de les tuer avec la
caméra
donc il fallait les amener devant une
et pour ça il fallait les faire parler
il fallait retrouver d'abord ce qui
était très très difficile bon ensuite
les convaincre non pas d'être filmée
parce que les vrais nazis ceux qui ont
trempé dans l'extermination ne parle
jamais ils n'ont pas parlé depuis 1945
même pas leur procès le process a
toujours été la dénégation
donc ils n'ont jamais parlé et a
fortiori il ne se font pas filmer donc
je les ai filmé par des méthodes à moi
enfin disons à leur insu puisque je vais
pas le cacher on le voit dans le film je
vais montrer comment j'ai comment j'ai
procédé et je les ai fait parler
certains ne me connaissent pas ne savait
pas qui j'étais
d'autres me connaissez sous mon nom
parce que j'avais réussi à établir avec
eux des vraies relations ça a été long
mais j'avais un seul devoir qui a été de
transmettre et pour transmettre
il fallait demeurer froid je n'avais pas
écouté deux oreilles mais rejeté par mes
propres émotions
je suis absolument demeurer froid oui
absolument sinon je n'aurais rien pu
faire et qu'est ce que vous avez pensé
alors de sujets d'effroi pendant pendant
11 ans qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de
ce juif l'autre jour qui disait moi je
l'aurais c'est son problème
une question de
moi je ne souhaite pas qu'on les tue moi
je suis pas du tout un chasseur de nazis
j'espère qu'on les mettre dans les
réserves et qu'on préserve leur mémoire
on qu'on les garde intact le plus
longtemps possible
[Musique]